imagine you're running a small business
you borrow some money you're paying it
back maybe you falling behind maybe you
have it and then one day out of the blue
you can't get any of your money out of
the bank your counts are locked up
they've been seized without any notice
to you this is happening to small
business people across America every day
and it's enabled by an obscured document
called a confession of judgment we just
kept getting worse there was no money
left I was so I'm ready to take my life
to clear everybody else I'm Zack miter
I'm a reporter at Bloomberg News I'm
Zeke Fox I'm a reporter for Bloomberg
News and Business Week magazine and were
the ones who wrote sign here to lose
everything
this is an extraordinary period for
America's economy we've seen triple
digit swings in the stock market
major financial institutions have
teetered on the edge of collapse and
some have failed after the financial
crisis a decade ago a lot of small
businesses needed loans and they
couldn't always get them from
traditional banks instead people who
stepped in were called cash advance
companies these guys call businesses
across the country and they're offering
quick money to say that if you're in a
tight spot they can get you fifty a
hundred grand overnight the loans are
very expensive with interest rates as
high as three hundred or five hundred
percent annualized that's 20 times as
much as you'd pay on a credit card the
merchant cash advance industry has
attracted all sorts of characters
because of the potential to make a quick
profit
so there are cash advance brokers with
convictions for drug smuggling stock
fraud if you go and talk to someone in
the shady side of Wall Street the odds
are they either working cash advance or
they've considered it one of the biggest
companies in the cash payment space is
Yellowstone capital and it was actually
founded by this guy David class I didn't
get to where I am today by losing my
clients money glass actually served as
the inspiration for the classic stocks
game movie boiler room you call me when
stock doubles all right
glass heard about this cash advance boom
and started Yellowstone and it quickly
grew to be one of the biggest cash
advance brokerages they're lending to
small businesses picture like a plumber
or an electrician or a shopkeeper but
they realized quickly that some
businesses were taking loans and then
just stealing the money essentially like
they had no intention of paying it back
so a lawyer working for Yellowstone and
some other cash advance companies had an
idea that they could revive this age-old
practice called confessions of judgment
a confession of judgment is something
that the borrower signs as a condition
of getting the loan it basically means
to give up their right to be heard in
court so later on if they miss a payment
or even if the lender wants to claim
they missed a payment it doesn't have to
be true the lender can go to quark with
this confession of judgment which gives
them the power to raid the borrower's
bank account confessions of judgment
aren't even valid in many states but New
York state law allows this practice the
borrower's are all across the country
Cleveland or Topeka Kansas or Los
Angeles but typically they're all
required to sign a confession of
judgment that's valid in a New York
Court when you stop and think about it
it's crazy that a borrower would admit
in advance to not paying back a loan
when they haven't even received the
money yet it was so illogical I really
wanted to know more we thought about now
maybe we should do a story but we didn't
have a sense of the scale like is this
something that's used a lot and we
ultimately found like more than 25,000
of these judgments filed in the last
couple years they were being used to go
after borrowers all over the country and
Yellowstone was filing these things at
our rate of like several a day
this system has no safeguards we found
lots of borrowers who said that
confessions of judgment were filed
against them when it was not warranted
or the cash advance company seized more
money than they were owed we found after
talking to borrowers that a lot of them
had had their lives turned upside down
by confessions of judgment my name is
Gerry Bush jr. um basically was a
plumber for about thirty years
Gerry Bush ran a plumbing business with
his father near Roanoke Virginia and the
company got a lot of jobs but he had
cashflow problems and he started taking
these cash advances a professional
judgment there was some party contract
you had to sign and they have very high
interest rates but we needed money so he
kept taking more and more of these loans
in order to get the money to pay the
loans he already had it got to be so bad
that he was paying back eighteen
thousand dollars a day at one point so I
had to close doors because there was no
way I could make the payments the way
these contracts work the cash events
companies shouldn't be able to go after
someone to collect if their business
fails but because Jerry had signed these
confessions of judgment the cash advance
companies went after him they've got my
father's retirement money they took my
son's account which he was seventeen but
they said my name was own account so
they took all his savings
I kept getting calls one funny company
told me he said you had two ways out win
a lottery or die I took the chance and
now I'm ready to take my life to clear
everybody else he took a lot of pain
pills walked out into the woods near his
house and recorded a video in which he
said goodbye to his son and wife they
found him and took him to the hospital
I'm surviving every day my hope is that
they will stop his confession judgments
I write to cinders Congress almost every
week and I'm just hoping we can get some
laws passed
[Music]
after we filed the story in November of
2018 we got quite a lot of response from
government officials on the federal
level members of Congress in both
chambers have filed legislation to end
the practice of confession-of-judgment
nationwide New York the state Attorney
General has opened an investigation and
among the companies they're looking at
our Yellowstone capital this is a story
that needed a light shone on it actively
by the press
if we hadn't published it when we did
you wouldn't see the official reaction
that you see now but while that's going
on people are still having confessions
of judgment filed against them every day
if you look up Yellowstone capital you
can see there are salesmen on Instagram
posting pictures of their Lamborghinis
diamond watches fancy vacations so they
seem to be doing great
even if confessions of judgment go away
there are all kinds of other abusive
practices in cash events industry from
brokers signing customers up for loans
they don't really want to lenders trying
to collect money they were never owed so
you're probably going to be hearing more
about this industry for years to come